lucía ruiz está viva de milagro
sobrevivió a un atentado de eta cuando
tenía 10 años en ese entonces vivía con
su padre miembro de la guardia civil y
con su familia en una casa cuartel
estaba ubicada aquí la casa cuartel de
la guardia civil en el año 1987 la banda
terrorista eta colocó un coche bomba con
250 kilos de explosivos
asesinando a 11 personas y dejando más
de 88 heridos
35 años después lucía todavía tiene
traumas sicológicos por el atentado mi
madre por ejemplo está prácticamente con
una movilidad reducida entonces el verla
pues te lo recuerda a diario y te lo
recuerda continuamente qué es lo que
pasó las heridas yo creo que es muy
difícil cerrarlas sobre todo cuando
continuamente salen noticias se acaba de
reabrir el juicio para ese atentado en
contra dijo su ternera jefe de eta en el
momento de los hechos actualmente se
encuentra detenido en francia tras 16
años de fuga
la justicia española pide su extradición
para poder determinar su rol exacto nos
queda saber bueno pues que él venga a la
audiencia nacional a responder por la
autoría intelectual del atentado aunque
las heridas no se cierren el hecho de
poder ver que por lo menos rinde cuentas
a la justicia porque creo que es lo que
cualquiera se merece
creo que es un paso importante
eta le puso fin a la lucha armada hace
10 años pero hay 350 atentados
atribuidos a la organización que siguen
sin resolverse
el recuerdo de las 850 víctimas del
grupo sigue presente en el país vasco la
sociedad sigue profundamente dividida
los familiares de los presos de eta se
reúnen en bilbao para esta manifestación
independentista
[Música]
todos critican una política
penitenciaria de excepción aplicadas y
30 años preventiva
los presos de eta fueron alejados de sus
casas para evitar agrupaciones delante
de las cárceles de los 174 presos que
quedan en el estado español la mitad son
los que están en comunidad la comunidad
autónoma vasca maider viso es la mujer
de un antiguo miembro del grupo
condenado por tres asesinatos está en la
cárcel desde hace 21 años según ella él
debería ser considerado como un preso
político están en la cárcel por una
motivación política por un conflicto al
final nosotros lo que pedimos es que
todos los nuestros familiares salgan a
la calle para la convivencia real si no
somos capaces de superar todos y cada
uno de los resquicios que quedan del
conflicto la gran mayoría de estos
ciudadanos votan por bildu el partido
independentista vasco varios de sus
miembros tenían relaciones con eta o con
sus partidarios
bildu es un aliado del gobierno de pedro
sánchez que lo necesita para mantener su
débil mayoría una coalición que divide a
los españoles
es inaceptable que el presidente del
gobierno funcione sable que un vaya a
dar
a los herederos de sus crímenes
por otro lado patxi lópez diputado
socialista vasco se alegra por la
presencia de bildu en el congreso para
el esa es la prueba de que se está
llevando a cabo un trabajo de memoria
tienen que elegir o bombas o votos y
ahora están aquí por la representación
que les dan los votos y ellos mismos
seguramente cuanto más participen de la
democracia más se darán cuenta qué
en un sistema democrático la violencia
nunca tiene cabida
en el país vasco esta voluntad de
pacificación está simbolizada por mas
abel las a su esposo un antiguo
gobernador socialista vasco fue
asesinado por un comando de eta en el
año 2000 se construyó un memorial para
rendirle homenaje más a bell lo visita
con frecuencia
el tener lugares físicos concretos en el
que se recuerda a una persona pues era
importante y son importantes
en el corazón de la montaña este
monumento representa su camino hacia la
resiliencia
todo lo que han hecho ha sido en balde
inútil totalmente lo único que han
producido es mucho dolor mucho
sufrimiento
y bueno pues eso hay que contarlo
maixabel fue una de las primeras
víctimas en haber aceptado encontrarse
con dos de los asesinos de su marido
quienes se arrepintieron
esta foto es cuando ibón echezarreta que
es uno de los que participó en el
asesinato de juan mari pues vino
me pidió el año 2014 la posibilidad
cuando estuve con él por primera vez de
venir a uno de los homenajes y le dije
que por mí no no tenía ningún
inconveniente
esta justicia restaurativa le permitió
seguir adelante y estar en paz con el
pasado su historia es contada en una
película que se estrenó este año el
largometraje atrajo a más de medio
millón de españoles a las salas de
opciones una prueba de que el tema sigue
despertando mucho interés
gracias a esto más abel espera poder
narrar el conflicto para que la historia
no se vuelva a repetir